- You posted this other adorable
picture of your daughter
and I love it.
(audience swoons)
- [Mindy] Oh yeah.
- So here's my thing.
I can kind of see a little girl
that's maybe dressed with ballet shoes.
Is your daughter at
ballet practice right now?
- Yes. So she's...
(audience laughs)
you can tell from this wallpaper,
she's at our dance...
look at this wallpaper, by the way.
- Oh, I didn't even
see the wallpaper. Wow.
- So she's at this dance school in L.A.
I mean, she's three, so it's not like
very rigorous or anything,
but it's a time when
like... I love girly stuff.
I love dressing her up in girly stuff
and she hates it.
But I thought, okay,
she's going to ballet,
she's pretty physical.
I got her, like, the tutu,
the little leotard, like everything.
Never wears it.
Will only wear this yellow Kobe Bryant
shorts and jersey set.
(audience applauds)
- I love it!
I love that she's so confident.
None of the other kids are wearing that.
She's just like, this is what I'm wearing.
And you're jealous. I'm aware.
- Yeah! She only... in her
mind, it's only appropriate
to be doing ballet in her favorite...
but you know what?
Kobe Bryant was a great
Laker, and a great...
we love him in Los Angeles, so I'm happy,
but I do wish she would
wear something more girly.
I gotta say.
- I have to have this argument.
I have this argument with my nanny,
and I'm like "Just let
her wear what she wants."
'Cause my mom just let
me wear whatever I want.
And I think it's kind of a
form of creativity, as well.
- [Mindy] Yeah, that's a good point.
And so, I'm just like, all right,
just be you, do you, you'll figure it out.
And my nanny is so funny.
She's like embarrassed
to be out with her.
(audience laughs)
'Cause some of the stuff she puts on...
definitely had Punky Brewster.
It's like, whoa.
- Don't you feel like you say that?
'Cause I'm also like...
let the child live their
own expressive life.
And then they put
something and you're like,
"That's heinous. You're not wearing that."
- I've actually never said that.
- You're such a good mom.
- No, here's...
it's not like I'm such a good mom...
I think it was a really
important thing for me to...
that was my way of expressing myself.
And I wasn't a writer yet,
and I wasn't a singer yet,
so much, when I was younger.
So I think it was a way of...
I loved it.
And I looked like a hot mess.
And sometimes Riv does
too, but it's awesome.
I love it.
- My daughter's gonna
watch this and be like,
"See? Kelly Clarkson says...
(audience laughs)
that I should wear whatever I want."
- And I'm like, "You will wear a dress."
- I'm abnormal though.
'Cause like, even my ex-husband was like,
"Are they gonna...they're not matching.
Their socks don't match
and their shoes..."
I'm like, "They're fine."
- That's better.
Even I should do that.
That's probably the answer.
- I don't know if it's the
best thing, but I do it.
I should probably read a parenting book.
It's probably a no no.
(audience applauds)
So you started writing
at six. That's amazing!
So what's one favorite
thing you wrote as a kid?
- Okay. Well, when I say writing,
I don't mean like it was so amazing-
- No I know, but you loved it.
- I loved writing since I was very little,
and my mom was a doctor,
and after school I was like
the typical latchkey kid
where instead of going home,
I'd just go to her office
and she'd just put me in
one of her little rooms.
She was an OB-GYN.
So I was in the room where
they, like, took blood.
- That could be frightening for a girl.
- Yeah. So we were in the room
where they would draw blood.
So, patients would come in and draw blood.
And my mom was like, just don't, like,
look at anyone and be weird.
So she gave me a little typewriter.
And then, I would sit in the corner,
and she's like, "You can
either read, or you can write."
There was like, I wasn't
allowed to watch TV,
I didn't have comic books or anything.
And so I was like-
- What a great investment she gave you.
Like, wow. You're like
a phenomenal writer now.
- Yeah, although, at
that time, I was like,
I wish that we could just
have like a Nintendo,
like a normal kid.
- Yeah.
- But anyway, so I would just
write these little plays.
And then, in between my mom's patients,
I'd run out, and a
pregnant woman would leave,
and she'd be like, "Okay,
I have five minutes."
And I would show her a little
page of a play that I wrote.
And so, I wrote this one play
about a haunted house
where like a werewolf and a
witch and a vampire lived in.
- I love that.
- And I would write all these things,
and I'd be like, "What do
you think? Are they funny?"
And she was such a tough critic.
She would be like, "No."
- [Kelly] So was my mother!
- Such a tough critic!
- Yeah!
- And I think it helped me.
- Me too!
And then this one, she
was like, "I love it."
And I remember at that moment being like,
oh, this pride I feel...
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Like I just wanted
to chase that feeling.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And so I just went back
to that weird little room in her office,
and I just kept writing stuff.
- I love that, though.
Speaking of parents, though,
my mom could be tough on me, too,
and say, "A lot of people have a dream
to do what you wanna do. It's hard work."
She was very realistic.
- [Mindy] Yeah.
- But I think a lot of parents
should be more realistic with kids.
Obviously support them, and their dreams,
but like... I don't know.
- [Mindy] Right.
- You see those people that you're like,
oh, everyone told you that
your poo smells like roses
your entire life.
(audience laughs)
Everything you did is magical.
And they're so entitled.
- Yeah.
- And I think it's good that
we have parents like that.
But you did deserve a Nintendo.
- It's interesting about it, though,
is it's not modern, right?
'Cause now, I'm sure your
kids, when they go to school...
Exactly. It's like you get
a trophy for participation.
And if I got one of those,
my mom would throw it away.
- Oh my god! I'm a Texan,
we don't believe in that.
- Yeah! Yes.
- We're like...
'Cause you have to teach
your kids how to lose.
- Yes.
- Yeah. That's it.
I am not being offensive
to kids or parents that think otherwise.
But I just mean,
that is an important lesson for my kid
to learn how to lose.
Like when we're playing a game,
I don't let her win all the time.
You gotta learn how to lose!
'Cause you gotta learn how that feels
and work through that emotional
state that sucks, you know?
- Yeah. No, a hundred percent.
- Yeah. Well, this is
a great conversation.
So you started out as
the only female writer
for The Office.
Was that like... horrifying or hard?
It seems awkward.
If you were walking in there being like,
"Yeah, my jokes are awesome."
- Yeah, so this was back in 2004.
I was 24.
- That's...a long time ago.
- Long time ago.
And I think there's, like,
there's been so many changes now,
but the thing is,
most of the people who were on The Office
in the writers' room,
are still my friend now,
I was really lucky.
But yeah, I was the only woman,
only person of color on the writing staff.
But I think it was really useful to me.
Because what I learned was like,
Okay. I just have to impress these guys.
I know I don't necessarily look like them,
but I would show up an hour early,
I'd leave an hour after everyone else did.
Even if I didn't have any work to do.
Just 'cause I wanted to give
the appearance of, like...
I am the hardest working person here.
- Yeah.
- Because, you know,
I didn't have any
experience writing in TV.
- And you'd feel like
you have to work harder.
- And I felt like I had to work harder!
And, I have to say, it was
a great lesson to learn,
'cause I did work harder.
But then, it's like,
I wrote the most episodes in The Office
of any writer there.
I wrote 24 episodes.
- That's amazing!
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
- God, what a funny show, too, wow.
- I think it's like...
it's a double edged sword.
I feel like, what I tell my daughter,
and a lot of my friends who are women,
and women of color, is like...
if we think of it as like,
"Oh great, I have to work so
much harder to prove myself,"
but it's like,
"Oh, great. I have the
opportunity to work harder,
and learn more, and prove myself."
And so, I think putting
in all that extra time,
back in the day, really
prepared me for like...
having my own show when I had my own show,
which I'm sure, you know...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You felt like, "Whoa, I'm
so happy I worked so hard."
- Oh, I had to be a hard
worker my whole life.
But I think that panned out well.
- And I also, if I can say this, too,
I was never this traditionally
beautiful-on-camera person,
and I felt like I was
like, it doesn't matter.
I have something else,
which is that I can write.
I can do this other thing.
And it made me... special.
And so, beauty fades,
and I'll still be able to be
writing in the corner at home.
- But here's what's funny,
'cause you walked out and I was like,
"Good gosh, you're beautiful."
So that's so funny.
- (laughs) I'll take it.
- No, it's how see ourselves.
'Cause I don't see myself as that, either.
And I always have to make
jokes when people make...
I feel like I'm Funny Girl,
like Fanny Brice in Funny Girl,
when they ask her to
sing a beautiful song,
and she's like... not without humor.
And I'm like, yeah, can't do it.
And I think that's me too.
But I think all of that
is character-building,
and I do think that it
makes you focus on...
when you aren't, that's not
your focus, you focus on
your actual gifts and your
talents, and what you really
wanna accomplish. So, I think that's good.